[Musique]
l'allemagne avait succombé
seul le japon résister encore et le 6
août 1945
l'amérique lançait une première bombe
atomique sur hiroshima le colonel paul
tibbets pilote de l'avion pouvait
envoyer ce simple message vu la ville
les détruit
[Musique]
hiroshima avait cessé d'exister en
quelques secondes des médias de
personnes furent brûlés tandis que les
maisons les usines les murs aplatissait
comme des châteaux de cartes
les arbres disparaissait dans les
flammes l'herbe flambait comme de la
paille
[Musique]
sur le sol a jamais photographié l'ombre
des pilier d'un pont
[Musique]
sept ans plus tard la commission d'étude
sur les effets des radiations atomiques
étudiait encore l'incidence à long terme
des radiations sur le corps humain
qu'elle était exactement les effets de
cette bombe qui laissait des traces
indélébiles sur tout ce qu'elle avait
touchés
l'empereur hirohito qui avait ordonné de
tolérer l'intolérable de supporter
l'insupportable allaitent inaugurait la
nouvelle hiroshima
car au japon les maisons sont de bois et
poussent comme des champignons
[Musique]
la vie reprenait mais les japonais
n'étaient pas prêts d'oublier les trente
sept mille cinq cents blessés et les 78
mille 150 morts d'hiroshima
[Musique]